today we're going to be speaking with
claudia golden who's a professor of
economics at harvard university and
author of the new book career and family
women's centurylong journey toward
equity it's really great to have you on
today i appreciate your time i'm pleased
to be here
so i i think maybe to start our
conversation it might be interesting as
you catalog
in the book
to talk about some of the catalysts over
the last hundred years
that have led women to enter the
workforce in greater numbers now that
than at any previous time can you talk a
little bit about kind of the main
highlights on these last 100 years
certainly so so to begin with
in fact the most important change in the
labor force in almost every country in
the world has been the increase
of women uh in the workforce uh so so
this decision is sort of made by
considering
what we call the opportunity cost of of
being in the household so when paid work
is more remunerative
it it's worth more relative to home
production you exit that household and
you go to work you know and this can uh
come about because real wages increase
it can also come about because household
production has better alternatives all
you have to think about
is what it would be like to bake bread
yourself rather than buying it of course
lots of people bake bread and they do a
very good job
but
and and it might also be furthered when
social norms and traditions change so
you asked about
uh the catalyst so technological change
of lots of different types did it
so the most important ones are the ones
that decreased the importance of what we
call broad work now i'm really strong
i'm stronger than my husband i know but
there are a lot of men who are stronger
than i am
uh and it increased the value of brain
work that's really very important so
uh and then there are the technologies
that made homes cleaner and their care
less labor-intensive you know we forget
about the fact we take for granted that
we have clean water and sewage removal
we have flushed toilets and central
heating and household electricity and
finally there are those that enabled
women to control their fertility it's
really very very important
and
that led to
an enormously large increase in the age
of first marriage in as late as the
1970s
uh the birth control pill
finally diffused among among young women
so those are the main ones
you um have spoken about in in the new
book you talk about the significantly
increased rate of women who get college
degrees and at a very top level we know
that at least right now this may change
but at least right now people with
college degrees have higher lifetime
earnings can you talk a little bit about
the the educational component to this as
well
sure so i think that you're asking why
it is that women versus men
uh get more degrees so so the returns
are extremely high on the margin
uh all these you know the vast majority
of individuals who don't get a college
degree would do much better if they if
they did that's not true for everyone
but it's true on the margin
but first a few important facts that are
generally not known
there have been more female college
graduates in the u.s than male college
graduates since around 1980 so therefore
it didn't happen yesterday it didn't
even happen 10 years ago it began
believe it or not 40 years ago
the second fact of importance is that
when high school graduation was a really
important milestone
and when just 10 to 20 of the nation's
young
people would cross that threshold and i
mean like in the first quarter century
of the the the first quarter of the 20th
century
uh women were the vast majority of high
school graduates okay that's an
important fact and the third fact is
that there are more female than male
college graduates in virtually all the
rich countries in the world
and even in the poorer countries women
are increasing their numbers relative to
men
so we and to understand what's going on
we have to take all of this into
consideration so two facts
or two notions the first is that work
for men is still partially brawn driven
so guys can still do construction work
go to any construction site how many
women do you see very very few
uh and so men even without a college
degree can still find
uh work that we used to call good work
it's become less and less good although
the demand for
non-college graduates today is very hard
and the second point
is that men
let's call them males because most of
them are very young don't get their act
together until later in life
and this is reflected in just a host of
risky behaviors from drugs to crime to
those that result in their own bodily
harm and so those who study psychology
and genetics can point to some of the
underlying reasons and it means that the
boys don't write their college essays on
time and they don't apply on time and
they don't go
when we
talk about this issue with most
americans who are sort of centered in
the political debates of our time
a lot of the factors that you're talking
about to build up this foundation of our
understanding of the dynamics of the
workforce
often get sort of tested by the final
output which is what does pay look like
and and questions of pay disparity and
for a very long time this idea of the 77
cents on the dollar was being floated
about
about eight years ago we did a kind of
deeper dive into this and and some of
your research was actually part of of
what we used to figure out what a maybe
more accurate number is and it seems
that the 77 cent number is simply not an
accurate number from what i'm recalling
now from the research it seemed to be
closer to 92 cents on the dollar
some part of which might be due to
discrimination can you talk a little bit
about that okay
okay i know this is a huge can of worms
i understand
as someone said a can of worms larger
than the universe which is a little
scary
so the first thing is that
first of all it's not 77 it's 82 i
believe but it is an accurate number for
something everything's an accurate
number if i told you the price of apples
you know in the corner store that would
be an accurate number for the price of
apples at the corner store maybe not be
the correct number for the price of
apples in san diego or omaha
so that that's part of the issue so it
is constructed
by taking
everyone in the current population
survey
taking their weekly earnings
for men and women
and using only those who are full-time
year-round so that that sort of
standardizes in some manner not entirely
and then takes the median for women and
the median for men and divides that's a
number it's an accurate number for what
it's doing okay here's the inaccuracies
the inaccuracies are that
for each woman
the
amount that she receives relative to men
changes over her lifetime we know that
we know that for relatively young men
and women their earnings are pretty
similar you know if i look at what
happens to
college graduates or law school
graduates
when they first leave their earnings are
very similar
and then over time they diverge and they
diverge a tremendous amount for those
at the highest end the professionals so
lawyers so
two lawyers might both both go to a park
avenue law firm and then they marry they
have kids and they realize it's
unsustainable
and so what happens is that it's often
the case
that the woman will
remain a lawyer
but move to a firm that's smaller and
less demanding less greedy
the difference between their earnings
that ratio isn't 77 it's not 92. it's
often 64. you know but we generally
don't observe in
census data where since we're
narrowing this we're looking at the
medians these are
the very very upper tail if we looked at
the lower tail
then they're going to be far
more similar it's almost ironic i've
often been asked uh isn't the gender gap
whiter at the bottom and i said i'm
going to be whiter at the bottom we've
got
a uh
we've got a bottom that's limited by the
minimum wage so it's not as if you have
so much room at the bottom you have a
tremendous amount of room at the top and
so that's that's the issue
so it is a correct number but it's not a
number that's going to tell us a lot
about what's happening
to
uh the uh individuals as they go through
their life cycle that's very interesting
so and with your
study being in economics
you're able to
explore
a number of different ways of measuring
this depending on what is the question
that we are sort of trying to answer and
then it seems that a second layer on top
of this would be if one wants to ask
political questions or societal
questions about discrimination we need
to be very careful about
what are the numbers that we're
considering it sounds like
absolutely i mean it's my sense
that there's no question that there are
disparities that we should eliminate
there's sexual harassment
there's uh disparities in terms of the
ability of individuals to go to a
supervisor and ask
for a raise there's real discrimination
but it's my
sense and we have a lot of information
that shows this that even if we
eradicated all of that and i hope we do
eradicate all of that it's not going to
close the gap because much of the gap is
due to this notion of greedy work and
the fact that in
couples that are different sex couples
they often
abandon gender equity
as i just said with the couple who
graduated from law school and when they
abandoned couple equity they throw
gender equality under the bus with it
when you uh in the book talk about
various anti-discrimination laws
training for people in managerial and
supervisory positions
my understanding and my reading of it is
you do find that these um
initiatives are valuable but that
they're not necessarily enough is that
fair yeah i i would say that they're
it's not that they're not necessarily
enough
they're not really getting to the main
problem
and when you if we really want to
fine-tune
or ascertain
the problem it seems there's a number of
components to some degree i mean you
talked about the dynamic within opposite
sex couples and career choices that
exist there
you talked about the difference between
what we might consider
uh higher wage jobs rather than than
middle or lower wage jobs can you talk
to us about some of the other
specific points that should be looked at
when we are trying to identify exactly
what the problem to be addressed is
uh certainly uh so they the
problem in many ways
is that work
a lot of work is very greedy and so when
individuals
couples are making these choices
they can
and and they have care responsibilities
they can both take
the more flexible
job that allows them to
respond to
emergencies that allows them a certain
amount of flexibility without penalty
but if they do that and the world is
very greedy they're leaving a lot of
money on the table it's it's really as
simple as that
um greedy jobs also impact those at the
lower end
but that's a somewhat different story
but it's it's the it it's really the
case
that for
uh many
uh couples
uh they're faced with a difficult
problem
as to whose career
is going to uh get the upper hand let's
say but at the same time
there's no question that both members of
the couple lose out
because men lose out of the joys and and
uh of of seeing their family uh
in the same amount of time that that
women do and women lose out because
their careers are uh in many ways
lowered and they're lowered for their
lifetimes
last thing i want to ask about programs
like universal pre-k
publicly funded child care etc
it might seem as though if these are
funded through taxes
and they provide
both parents for lack of a better term
with a more equalizing opportunity to
remain in the workforce in a more
engaged way it would seem as though
programs like that might have an
equalizing force is is that the case
yeah so
so let's think about it there are three
types of solutions
one is to lower the price of these
flexible jobs make them more productive
that that's the one that i that i spend
a lot of time on the second one is to
lower the price of care of of children
i'm not just children but of the elderly
and we that's another set of issues
and the third type of solution is simply
to change gender norms because
if in fact
when given this choice it was random
then you might throw couple equity under
the bus but you wouldn't throw gender
equality under the bus with it okay but
let's talk about you it's a somewhat
separate
issue to talk about universal pre-k and
publicly funded child care that would
certainly change the price of care it
would drive it down
relative to the amount that you get from
working
by the way
it would
also be the case that if we change tax
policy that might be a good thing to do
too so if we didn't have joint returns
as is the case in britain and sweden uh
then uh
uh
women wouldn't
in some sense be faced within the family
by the higher
marginal
tax rate so that would be a very good
thing too
but the problem is that someone has to
pay for universal pre-k in child care
and the latter
child care
is extremely expensive as anyone with
children knows i mean everyone complains
it's very interesting that
everyone with children complains about
the high cost of child care
and at the same time they complained
that child care workers are paid too
little
so
right where do you think the costs come
from right
it's it's it's a very very simple point
if you have
one child care worker
for three children
just do the math and it's very very
clear that if you're actually if you're
a child care worker is well educated
well-skilled and well-paid it's going to
cost a tremendous amount so these are
decisions for the politics sweden
decided that they did want to go that
route not for infants by the way for
infants they uh the one of the parents
receives uh parental leave and is paid
for that
so as researchers though we can
demonstrate that pre-k
increases the human capital the next
generation
reversal pre-k
you didn't say pre-k you said universal
and that's important by involving the
entire community
is actually more effective
than targeted pre-k
um so
so that's uh uh sort of the answer
universal pre-k would be very very nice
i mean let's face it
we have public education at what age
should it begin
you know at some point in the 1920s
1930s it was decided that it we should
push it
to five
years old or six years old and have this
thing called kindergarten
uh at some point in the 20th century we
had universal kindergarten
so uh so there's no it's this is a
matter of the age
of three-year-olds four-year-olds can
learn
right and so
i guess
spoken as someone who has a
four-year-old
the new book is career and family
women's century-long journey toward
equity we've been speaking with the
book's author harvard university
economics professor claudia golden i
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
well thanks very much david i've enjoyed
it